[Música]
desde que tengo memoria he sido un
consumidor de la ciencia ficción como
casi cualquier millennial con acceso a
la tecnología fue influenciado por las
películas de los 80s y los noventas
devoraba libros de ciencia ficción donde
planteaban tecnologías que transformaban
civilizaciones completas o héroes que
viajaban a mundos digitales o lograban
llegar a otros planetas y sistemas
solares la interacción creció cuando
entré al mundo de los videojuegos y
pasaba semanas de mi vida mejorando mis
personajes virtuales en donde terminé
después de todo esto eventualmente me
convertí en programador de videojuegos y
tuve la fortuna de ahora ser yo parte
del proceso de creación de tecnologías y
de mundos virtuales
logré vivir el proceso donde una gran
cantidad de conceptos planteados
originalmente en la ciencia ficción se
convertían en tecnología real para su
uso en los videojuegos y después daban
el salto a intentar ayudar a resolver
problemas del mundo real
eventualmente llegó a la pantalla y una
situación en particular me empezó a
generar descontento porque ahora que
tenemos que aislarnos que tenemos que
perder contacto con nuestros seres
queridos que tenemos que cambiar
nuestras formas de colaborar con las
personas
porque ahora que más lo necesitamos no
estamos usando toda esta tecnología
lo que pasó durante la pandemia es que
hubo mayor adopción de tecnología pero
fue tecnología que ya estábamos
acostumbrados a usar y simplemente dimos
el paso a volverla cotidiana en nuestro
día a día por ejemplo las videollamadas
me refiero específicamente a tecnologías
como la realidad virtual o la realidad
aumentada para entrar en contexto
exploremos un poco sobre qué es la
realidad realidad virtual pero empezando
por la tecnología que conocemos
cuando vemos televisión o jugamos un
videojuego parte de lo que estamos
haciendo es engañar a nuestro cerebro
con señales creadas sintéticamente para
sumergir al usuario de un mundo o
historias distintas a la realidad que
estamos viviendo sin embargo los
sentidos del cuerpo humano son bastante
difíciles de engañar el cerebro
inmediatamente se da cuenta que está
observando una pantalla plana y no el
mundo real en cambio un casco de
realidad virtual es un dispositivo que
cuando se coloca en la cabeza engaña
casi en su totalidad a la vista humana
remueve al usuario de su mundo real y lo
transporta a un mundo virtual
esta tecnología incluso te permite
visualizar tus manos' en un mundo
virtual desplazarse e interactuar con
objetos virtuales como si lo hicieras en
el mundo real
ahora agreguemos unos audífonos y
tenemos todo listo para engañar al menos
tres sentidos del cuerpo humano el
sentido de la audición el sentido de la
vista y parte del tacto con el
desplazamiento que hacemos ahora con
todo esto
pues la lista de aplicaciones no para de
crecer por ejemplo videojuegos mucho más
realistas e inmersivos poder visitar
guanajuato virtualmente mientras nos
encontramos en otro país ver una
película en la sala del cine mientras
estamos sentados en el sillón de nuestra
casa e incluso realizar una cirugía a
distancia o entrenar de forma de forma
virtual un procedimiento laboral de muy
alto riesgo antes de realizarlo en el
mundo real dar clases remotas de forma
más interactiva con alumnos que no
tienen interés en clases en línea
todas estas aplicaciones suenan perfecto
para usarse durante una pandemia y
entonces no surge de nuevo la pregunta
porque no las estamos usando la
respuesta no es simple pero nos ayuda a
ver qué es lo que se aproxima
empecemos con una de las principales
razones el costo las tecnologías
inmersivas como la realidad virtual no
son baratas el precio de entrada para un
consumidor sigue siendo incluso más alto
que una computadora a una televisión
ocasionando que aún sea muy difícil para
una familia tener un casco de realidad
virtual en casa
por otro lado todo el contenido y
aplicaciones de realidad virtual que
alguien puede consumir dentro de su
casco se distribuye por medio de
plataformas cerradas
esto significa que si tú creas contenido
para un casco de realidad virtual de
alguna marca en específico no
necesariamente alguien que tiene un
casco de realidad virtual de otra marca
podrá disfrutar y disfrutar tu contenido
esto es un problema de compatibilidad
que ocasiona que los costos de
producción de aplicaciones incrementen y
por lo tanto no existe una gran cantidad
de aplicaciones y contenido para
realidad virtual
qué es lo que tiene que pasar para que
estos problemas sean superados
la respuesta es el metaverso y si nos
regresamos a la ciencia ficción con uno
de los libros que más me marcaron cuando
era más joven snow craig lengyel
stephenson un libro que curiosamente
menciona guanajuato en sus primeras
páginas pero es realmente famoso por
acuñar el término de el metaverso e
inspirar muchas obras de ciencia ficción
y tecnologías que son parte de nuestra
vida diaria por ejemplo the matrix ready
player one incluso la misma realidad
virtual
el metaverso es la unión de todos los
mundos virtuales es el sucesor del
internet que permite interactuar
virtualmente entre nosotros de una forma
mucho más inmersiva
por ejemplo si tienes tu avatar virtual
podrás ser el héroe de cualquier
videojuego usando siempre tu mismo
avatar podrás ir a una videoconferencia
del trabajo con él o visitar un amigo
que vive en otro continente en su casa
virtual pero dentro del metaverso podrás
comprar un espacio de el metaverso y
construir digitalmente lo que tú quieras
allí una casa virtual o una tienda para
vender bienes digitales por medio de
blogs e incluso objetos físicos que
maneras después por paquetería
todos los elementos necesarios para
crear el metaverso ya existen por
ejemplo la primera necesidad ya la
mencionamos si queremos interactuar
virtualmente con los sentidos de nuestro
cuerpo la realidad virtual ya nos
permite esta interacción humano máquina
también necesitamos mundos virtuales
para el metaverso en donde los
encontramos en los videojuegos con sus
mundos virtuales cada vez más complejos
e interactivos por otro lado se
necesitará una red donde todo esté
conectado y afortunadamente ya tenemos
el internet que nos demuestra como un
sistema abierto nos permite comunicarnos
entre nosotros y compartir contenido a
todo el mundo
además es importante que podamos entrar
al metaverso desde cualquier lugar para
esto nos ayudará a la red 5g que nos
permite transferir grandes cantidades de
informaciones desde cualquier lugar que
nos encontremos y por último queremos
ser dueños de objetos y lugares de el
metaverso poder vender y comprar bienes
digitales gracias al blog change tenemos
los nets y tokens no fungibles que nos
permiten que un objeto virtual sea único
y transferible esta tecnología ya se usa
abiertamente para vender arte digital y
objetos dentro de los videojuegos el
siguiente paso es lograr conectar todo
esto diseñar estándares libres que nos
permitan vincular todas las tecnologías
que son necesarias para crear un
metaverso
necesitamos que cualquier contenido que
creamos como videojuego
páginas web redes sociales se pueden
usar desde el metaverso sin importar el
lugar en el que te encuentres o el casco
de realidad virtual que estés usando el
metaverso es algo que predominará más
pronto de lo que esperamos es el
siguiente paso natural de la interacción
que ya tenemos de manera virtual el
cambio llegará tan rápido que antes de
lo esperado nos tendremos que preguntar
cuáles serán las consecuencias de este
paso virtual cuáles serán los problemas
éticos de una plataforma tan abierta e
inmersiva todas las historias famosas de
ciencia ficción sobre metaversos tratan
más sobre una distopía por eso tenemos
que trabajar en conjunto para que el
metaverso se acerque más a una utopía
que a una distopía muchas gracias